あの またもう一つ 思考はどのように管理するべきかということを教えている経典があります
マッジムニカへの 20番目の経典で
名前はヴィパッサナーというんですね
この経典で思考妄想を制御管理する方法を教えているんです
サンターナとは安全を確保するという意味です
思考妄想の安全を確保しておくんです
ヴィパッサナーとは思考妄想のことですね
ヴィパッサナー 思考妄想を安全にしておくという
原子爆弾でもね 自動的には爆発しませんだからね
あれは結構難しいんですよ
だからかなりもう安全にということにしていますよ
で 管理法をまた順番できます
一 欲 怒り 無知の感情で思考が流れるようになる
はい この場合は無知も入ります
この経典では 我々の思考は欲
怒り 無知でも流れるようになりますね
その時 思考の対象を変えて別なことを考えることにする
まあ例えば 田舎にいる初恋の人のことを思い出したらね
あー楽しかったなとかね
欲しかったなとかいろいろ考えたりすると
もう欲が出てくるんですね
そうするときれいさっぱりそれ忘れちゃって
それではなくて もう今日仕事でレポートはどう書けばいいかどうかね
全く別なことに心を持っていけば
なんか例えば会社で課長に怒鳴られて
もうすっごい機嫌が悪くなって
もう怒りに狂っていると
ずっとそれを持つんだね
あ これダメや じゃあ子供のこと考えようと
自分のあいつはかわいいやとかね
考えるときれいさっぱり消えますよ
はい 子供と遊びましょうと言って
自分の子供と遊べばいいんですね
そういう風にこの対象を変えるんですね
悪思考が消え 善思考が生まれたら
その思考も抑えて集中力に励む
お釈迦様は皆様に教えてないんだからね
これはもう悟りに頑張っているお坊さんたちに教えた経典だから
はい それで修行するお坊さんの頭の中に悪い思考が出てきたら
すぐテーマを変えるんです
ブッダのことを考えたりとかね
サーリプッタ尊者のことを考えたりとかね
テーマを変えるんです
それで心はきれいになる
だからといってきれいな思考でいるわけ言ってはならんです
きれいな思考でも それからその思考もやめて集中力を育てる
太い釘を細い釘で抜くように
それでお釈迦様は明確な例えがありますね
何か何かに釘が入ってますね
これ結構太いんです 抜けませんね
中に入っている そうすると細い釘を打つんです
あの釘よりは細い釘を打つと
あの釘が抜けちゃうんです
それでこの釘も抜けられます
同じ釘を打っちゃうと
同じ大きさのね それがまた空いちゃいますからね
もう抜けられなくなります
だから細い釘を打ってから元の釘を抜けますね
それから今の釘も取り出したらもう外せます
そのやり方ですと 二 一つの方法があ
一の方法が失敗したならば
悪思考の欠点 危険性を明確に観察することにする
別なことを考えようと思っても
ダメな場合ありますね
それでも思っちゃうというね
ちょっとタチが悪いんですね
妄想の その場合はそれだったらこんな思考っていいのかと
この危険性を徹底的に考えちゃうんです
まあ例えば欲の思考が生まれたら
これでいると私は痴漢するかもしれませんし
変なことするかもしれませんしとかね
ストーカーになるかもしれませんとかね
危ない危ないと まとめに人間で喋らなくなっちゃうしね
なんか下品な言葉を言うかもしれませんしということで
あ ダメダメだということで
危険性を考えてやめられることはできます
妄想自体が気持ち悪くなってなくなる
そうすると 今の思考 なんだ気持ち悪い思考と思ってなくなるんです
たとえおしゃれ好きな若者が犬
蛇 猫の死骸を体に付けられることは嫌うように
例えば若者ですっごいおしゃれ好き
その子に猫の死骸を首に
はい これを持って首に飾ってくださいとか
ものすごい気持ち悪くなるでしょうに
じゃあヘビネックレスの代わりにこの死んだヘビを首にかけてください
やるわけじゃないんで
それぐらい自分の妄想思考が気持ち悪くなるんですよ
この危険性を観察すると
管理さん  2番目の方法もダメになったらどうしますかね
悪い悪いと知っても知ってもやっちゃう場合もありますね
本当は汚い こんな思考はね
本当に悪いとかね 知ってもやる場合あります
その場合はアサティアマニスカールアパジタンポ
その思考を単純にしないことに
無視することに 止めることにするんです
まあどうでもいい じゃあやめますということでやめるんです
これ単純にできますよ
本当は いわゆるそれに関わらないことにする
アサティっていうのはサティの反対です
アマニスカラっていうのは作為といって考えることですね
まあまあやめますということで
そこはもうやめるんです
このサティの反対もいい時ありますよ
妄想に対してはサティ入れてはならんです
妄想にすぐ気づいちゃうと
どんどんどんどん妄想しちゃうんです
妄想に乗らない 誘惑されないという意味なんですね
何か妄想が生まれたんだけど
乗らない その思考に 誘惑されないことにする
これ微妙にレベル高いんです
いわゆる頭の中でいろいろ妄想があるんだけど
もう関係ないことにするんです
で そこは3番目のステップです
見たくないものが目の前である場合は目を閉じるんです
例えば 例えば ものすごい見たくないことを自分の前に持ってくると
目を閉じればいいでしょ
そういうことで まあ悪思考はやめられますと
4番目 3番目の方法もダメでしたらどうしますか？と
ヴィタッカサンカーラサンターナマンシカータッバ
妄想を引き起こしている衝動
感情 原因を観察する なんで私はこんな妄想してるんですかね？どんな感情ですかね
その妄想を引き起こした原因をね
感情を観察するんです
これは欲でしょうと これは怒りでしょうと
いうふうにするんです
言い訳じゃないんですよね
結構言い訳する人々も私と話しますけど
それはものすごく腹が立ちますね
その時は 妄想に言い訳するんじゃないんです
かつてそういうことがあったんだから
今こんな妄想してるんだと
そんなのはどうでもいいんです
怒りか欲か無知かと 私は無知だからこんなことを考えているんだというふうに
その原因を この衝動を発見するんです
修行の目的と 原因 の目的になっていることは見えてくるんですね
例えばお坊さんの例で考えてください
お坊さんが出家して森に入って瞑想しようとする
そうすると 繊細のことを思い出したり
子供のことを思い出したり
仲間と仕事をしたことを思い出したり
あー楽しかったなとかね
となっちゃうとどうなるんですかね
それで修行と反対でしょうに
捨てる世界に入ってるんだから
それでその人は ああ これは欲だ
私は出家といったって
まだ家のこと考えているんだ
これは欲だ 執着だと 執着がこの妄想を作っているんだと観察するんですね
そうすると この自分がこの仏道の反対のことをやっているんだ
例えば勉強真っ最中で余計なことを考え出したら
面白いんだから考えるそうではなくて
こんなのは勉強は嫌いだからふざけたいという気持ちで変なことを考えている
そんなことを考えちゃうと
勉強の道とは反対だと
頭が良くなる道と反対だ
これじゃダメやって それでやめられます
この例えがありまして
この楽しいハイキングに出た人は早く歩いたり
ゆっくり歩いたり やめたり
休んだりするようにと
という長いたとえ話ですけど
短くしました 例えば昔は旅に出るんだからね
人々はね 歩いていくんですね
それで早く行かなくちゃって
もう焦って歩くとクタクタ疲れるんですよ
なんで早く歩かなくてもいいんじゃないかと
ゆっくり歩く ハイキングの例は一番いいんですよね
ハイキングの場合は 時々じゃあ早く行きましょう
早く行きましょうと 早い足で行かなくちゃいけない時もあって
まあゆっくり行かなくちゃいけない時もあって
まあここら辺でまあちょっと休みましょうと
それからここら辺でハイキングはやめましょう
終わりよというふうなことなんですね
そういうふうに自分の思考を衝動を見て管理するんだと
これは欲だ これは怒りだとわかって
そこはやめて 良い思考にして
じゃあ良い思考もやめますよと
最終的には思考停止に挑戦するんです
だから 仏典からいうと
必ず最終的には思考停止なんです
5番目  4つの方法も失敗したならば
重度の妄想になっているんですね
あれもダメだったらね
欲や怒りだとわかってもやっちゃったらどうしますかね
かなり重度です その場合はチッタンアビニッカリタッバン
アビニッピーレタッバン
アビサンターペータッバン
舌を顎につけて歯を噛んで心を非難する
責める いじめる 痛み続ける
もう方法も常性もないんです
悪思考悪いんです その時はものすごく歯を噛んででもやめなさいと
逆立ちしてでもやめてほしいんです
首はダメですから 足にロープをつけて自分をぶら下がってもらってでも
もう何でもいいんです
もうそれぐらい悪思考は良くないんです
妄想をやめるためなら何をやってもいいみたいということなんです
それは私の感想だから
括弧の中に入れたんです
苦行はダメな仏教でも
やっぱりこの場合はね
苦行でもいいんだよということなんです
はい それで終了やと思います
それで順番  1思考妄想を善思考で置き換えられる修行になります
まず 悪思考悪妄想を置き換えられます
良い思考で良い妄想で
一般的に語られる仏教はこの目的を目指しているんです
皆様 いろんなところで説法を聞いたり
本を読んだり 仏教の国々でもね
よく頑張っています ほとんど良いことをしましょう
悪いことをやめましょう
お布施をしましょう お寺を作りましょうという話なんですよ
涅槃に入りましょうと話に出てこないんです
ほとんどやがて涅槃に入りますと
やがてなんです この道を歩んで
結局は仏教の世界 日本の仏教も同じですよ
いい人間になりましょう
ビシビシ頑張りましょうという説法なんですね
それでどうしたって どうしたと聞きたくなるんだけどね
あんた方 あなたに言われなくてもいい人間になろうとして失敗していますけどとかね
大寺のお坊さんに言われてんだからできるわけないでしょうに
できることなら お寺のお坊さんが言わなくたってもやりますよ
人間は しかし 教会の説法にしたっても
お寺の説法にしたっても
もう仏教の国々の説法にしたっても
そんな程度ですよ 悪思考をやめる
良い人間になる道を教えているんです
仏教はそれで終わらないんです
2番目 善思考も止めて
サティの実践で集中力を高めて
思考の停止非治療を目指すのです
いわゆる解脱を目指すのです
これは解脱に達する方法です
思考の停止は解脱なんです
ということで 順番に頑張るんですね
これで話は終わりと思います
だから 妄想を止められないならば
思考をしっかりと整理整頓しましょうと
すごい立派な もう想像できないほど立派な人間にもなるし
精神的な病気は全てなくなるし
はい これで話を終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます